thank you for having me i'm very pleased
to share our research and findings with
the plant breeding community
i'm at on that security by name the
topic of my presentation is
methodologies to improve the efficiency
of genomic selection in siemens
mainspreader program
these are the outline of my presentation
my background
introduction to sigma genomic selection
pipeline where we have where we want to
be
material as a method
research and discussion
and uh conclusion
from our results
once again i'm security by name
i have my via greek and msc plant
breeding from the university of hillary
in nigeria
and the host institution
from academic marketing program
is west africa central crop improvement
universal of ghana
where i have my research conducted at
international maize and with
improvements in custom in mexico
in collaboration with kelly robins lab
in conney
the presentation is actually an excerpt
of my video research work
you are presently a postdoc
with the global base with the google
width program in siemens
so i'll begin my presentation with uh
the predator equation because it's a
useful starting point
then the fundamental application of
quantity genetics to crop improvements
it has parameters that breeder can
manipulate to accelerogenetic gain and
parameters are genetic variation
selection intensity
uh
have which is a selection accuracy and
added section cycle time
y sigma g is a genetic
gain so the overhaul
objective of this presentation
is how
the maze blending program is using
genomic selection to
manipulate the parameters of the
predator equation and accelerate genetic
gain in the brain program
this is an overview of the semi traffic
coming spreading program where we have
where we're coming from rather so the
freedom make and invite
the breeder make a cross between two in
red line a and b and such process
community on red
generates f1 the f1 itself
to f2
and from the f2 dh line are derived you
derive the h line and test cross to
a test cross to test that from opposite
authoritative group and the test crosses
are evaluated in the stage one in three
to five location on the superior
lines advantage of stage two which are
further tested more testers and test
crosses are evaluated in five to eight
location
the superior line from stage two uh
advanced to stationary and uh also
further tested in four or
pesticides
processes
five
in more than 15 locations
uh and uh
lines with isc and gca
are used in either combination and
and the hybrid are evaluated in uh
and the hybrid are evaluated in more
than 50 locations which are eventually
released on the superior and the
superior hybrid eventually relates to
the farmers
so the
despite the success in the mainstream
program but yes
there's always an opportunity for an
improvement and optimization so the the
drawback of the philanthropic selection
is the faster it is expensive and time
taking for instance the stage one yeah
at the breeder
which is primarily a trial really pretty
i want to
evaluate the new line for
uh
potential
which are thousands of lines that i want
to evaluate at this stage which make it
very expensive at the same time it's the
breeder has to wait uh three to five
months depending on the maturity of the
maze before advancement decision can be
made to stage two
so what are the opportunities available
to accelerate a
genetic gain in this
maze braided program at the double ipad
technology which is already
used the chip genotyping platform and
the use of the the genomic selection to
manipulate the
uh the parameters of the radar equation
and accelerate genetically so where
the most where is cement actually uh
implementing genomic selection currently
implementing genomic selection in the
intestine stage is the stage one but
in the stage one given the fact that the
number of uh lines that the breeder
wants to evaluate at this stage are
numbers and i saw actually that can
reduce the number of individuals that
need to be tested advanced line advanced
promising line directly to stage two
using the gbv
so what is what is the current uh
genomic selection strategy that is being
used in the signature measurement
program is best have a predictor
which is which implies
that
each bipedal population is split into
two
half of which is uh
planted on the feed as the trendset
which is used to create a predictive
model and predict the generally created
genetic merit of compel type individual
so selection is being made
with a gbb at the same time with uh with
the glue
so this is the empirical evidence of
the efficiency of genomic selection in
the cement main spreader program
this has been published in 2019 where
individual that
have been selected using the gbv and
individual that we selected using the
inspection advanced stage 2 and planted
on the feed and so there are so that we
just saw that has been shown here
give
clear cut evidence that there is no
difference in the selection of policy
using the gbv and the pharmaceutical
selection at the stage one in the cement
may spread the program so what is the
implication of a strategy this this
quantum strategy so with this strategy
you can increase the selection intensity
there's increase in selection accuracy
however we are unable to reduce the
selection cycle time because
the breeders stay as a phenotype subset
of african population to predict more
than predict the
uh the genetic merit of the often type
of individuals so they're still delaying
decision making and also the cost of uh
generating the philanthropic record
which is utah as uh which is used as a
training site to predict the genetic
merit of the organ type
half of the population
in order to maximize the efficiency of
the
of this in order to maximize the
efficiency of genomic selection in the
cement measurement program and improve
uh depletion accuracy so we propose a
stepwise key which basically involved
the use of historical data as a training
site to predict the genetic
merit of new or by parental population
however because historical data is made
up of individuals that
are closely related to
the new population and those that are
distantly related so we use a genetic
optimization criteria to select
individual of the
from the historical data that are most
informative of the
new population
to train the predictive model and
generate the gbv so individual
advanced directly to stage two using
only the gbb and the scenario where
the historical data can now be
confidently used to predict the genetic
value of membranes of the new population
are the tests the radio currents still
use the test time predator and the
space testing however with the use of
genetic uh genetic optimization criteria
to select individual that will be
planted on the feed and individual shelf
in one of our publication which i'm not
going to present here so we find that
this past testing actually has
improved prediction and accuracy
compared to the tester from predator
given the fact that
all
individual half phenotypic data do in
the different uh locate in different
locations and in the scenario also where
we want to
in this scenario we also propose here is
phenotyping is subs
a few individuals from the
uh
from the population from the from the
new population and augments defensive
training with a
individual that's optimized from the
historical data and we also find out
that we also find that this also results
in uh improved uh prediction accuracy we
don't know we don't lose
accuracy even if we
phenotype
a
few subsets of the the new new
population and augments the diffusive
training with uh uh historical data
optimizing storage data
so these are genetic mapping the genetic
material used to test for the data
hypotheses are
materials from the
east
cement east east east african-american
program in 2017 and 2018 which consists
of 849 and one three eight nine dh line
derived from thirteen and forty five
population so the population domain
overlap across years and
uh a general type using repeats and
amplicon sequencing
in order to
test the hypotheses so we first use uh
the multiple perpendicular population
which has 45 by 45 population needs
highly diverse data sets and this is the
population structure of
the
data set in 2018
the first approach
was to predict
a population
using the remaining 45 using the
remaining four population as a transect
so
in this case i'm presenting only one of
the results which is population aids as
a training class which individual which
are 84
and the remaining
44 population which are which is a
1305 individual is used as a trading
site so we use
different optimization criteria to
select individual that
might be
informative of the uh the population
that we want to predict so we select 15
50 individual to 1000 individual so the
result shown here shows that
optimizing the training side
results in improved prediction accuracy
compared to using all the
individual training set as
us
in the individual in the individual and
the historical data as a training set so
with the use of see because we have
enough
have seen in the training set in the in
the training so we base we use the
pedigree information uh to select
individual that have half cpu sheet to
the new uh to the population of intro
that we want to predict and it it also
we also have the result that shown that
using that as a criteria it's a result
in
improved prediction abrasive compared to
using
all the
uh
all the individual nutrients say or on
individual historical data as the
trading sites
having this information
we will also be able to also determine
which of the
criteria consistently resulting in
propagation accuracy and we found that
cd mean and aphr
fhgr which is the average genetic
relationship between individual and
between the training population and the
fedora in the testing population are two
individual at two genetic criteria that
we identify to have a potential of
uh successing individuals that are most
closely related to
the
prediction population and this is a
genetic coverage of
the optimized strength side using the
using history uh
genetic optimization criteria so the ts
is the testosterone the t as is the blue
line is test instead and the crane which
is a individual data that's true that's
identified by the genetic optimization
criteria to be half c
to the
testing population and they and the
chocolate is uh individuals that don't
have pedigree but have been selected to
be informative over the trading
population and the trn individual that
are not selected which is the black
individual that are not selected at all
by the uh by the selection criteria so
given this
information here it shows that the fdrm
has individuals
that are within the genetic space of
intestinal cells likewise the cd means
the part of the cd may not still be
outside the genetic space of that of the
vertebrae of the
testing population however me
has
basically most of most of the
individuals have been selected outside
the genetic space of the population
which shows that it is not efficient in
in selecting individual that are most
informative of the of the testing sites
having this information so in order to
further test the efficiency of the two
uh identify optimization criteria so we
combine
the data cell in 2017 and 2018 using uh
the 2018 dataset which is highly diverse
to predict populations in 2017.
so what we find is the same as we have
in the in in the previous data set but
with
high
confidence that the cd main and fgr
consistently results in
improvisational policy compared to using
all the historical data as a as a
trading site
and this is the genetic coverage of the
optimized trading set uh using the cd
main and the future which is similar to
what i've presented before
so the conclusion here is
the breeder can use can leverage can use
uh
the historical data
to predict the genetic merit of
new population
by optimizing the historical data set to
calibrate
the predictive model to predict the
genetic merit of a new individual and
other fans directly to stage two without
uh testing
the new population in stage one
and
and also from the result we find that it
is unlikely to have a single large gpu
with high predictive accuracy uh across
the bridge population and uh in addition
for population that require targeted
phenotyping of the fosa criterions such
as the cdma should be employed to select
individual for
phenotyping
uh
these are my supervisors and
collaborators i'm grateful to them
and
thank you for
for the invitation and
you